the Queen's death has of course revived
a long simmering debate across parts of
the so-called British realm a debate
about whether it's time to cut ties with
the crown the realm made up of 14
countries plus the UK all these
countries symbolically at least hold the
British monarch as the head of state
more important even than their own
elected officials that includes
Australia it includes Canada also the
Bahamas Remy inocencio is in London for
us and he's going to walk us through
which countries are considered
considering deposing the Royals Ramey
good morning
good morning Queen Elizabeth's death has
cracked open the gates of criticism of
the crown as for those countries in
question they're all former British
colonies with tragic histories of
slavery
from Australia to the Bahamas
cannons boomed across the Commonwealth
as thousands of miles away Charles was
proclaimed King
head of the Commonwealth defender of the
faith but parts of the realm are
restless Jamaica's prime minister told
Prince William to his face the country
would be moving on from the monarchy
with a referendum expected by 2025.
protesters had also demanded an apology
and reparations for Britain's role in
the slave trade what is the biggest scar
on Jamaica because of the United Kingdom
I mean the whole idea of Jamaica is the
scar right Kai Hindi Andrews is the UK's
first professor of black studies the
Royal African company which is founded
by the Monarch was the one company that
enslaved more Africans than any other
company in the entire world and the
monarchy cannot be separated from
slavery at all but countries can
separate themselves from the monarchy
from The Darkest Days of our past
and the appalling atrocity of slavery
which forever stains our history like
the tiny West Indies island of Barbados
last November when then Prince Charles
congratulated one of the Realms on
breaking away and becoming the world's
newest Republic
a new president inaugurated replacing
then Queen Elizabeth as head of state as
a descendant of slaves I'm aware of the
very difficult and troubled history
Wesley Kerr is a royal historian and
points out the British Empire is long
gone but to survive the British Monarchy
needs to mix tradition and modernity
fewer people think that there will be a
monarchy in the next hundred years what
do you say to that I get to count the
millions of people out on the streets
this week I'm going to count the
millions of people at the Jubilee so I
see no sign of of the monarchy being in
trouble but it's got to prove itself to
every generation a recent poll in the UK
found support for the monarchy slipped
13 points in the past 10 years with
youth support dropping the most from
nearly two out of three to one out of
three the monarchy has lost its
relevance people are really suffering
financially at the moment and suddenly
we have 11 days of non-movement because
of tradition do you think King Charles
could ever be as loved and admired as
Queen Elizabeth no
with that enough what would you say to a
Critic who says the UK does not need the
monarchy anymore oh I would completely
disagree because it brings tourists in
and we welcome people and we want people
to come and see our history
and publicly King Charles says he
supports any realm country becoming a
republic if they want Gail
got it Romeo he raises a lot of
interesting questions as much loved and
revered as the queen was is and is there
are still some people that say there
need to be some changes it'll be
interesting to see what King Charles
does of anything it seems likely that
there will be more Realms that will
detach and become independent but it
seems unlikely that the UK is going to
do away with what is a huge branding
Bonanza there is a lot of Tourism
involved in in visiting the Royal
residences absolutely true